Iran comment vit-on quotidiennement dans
ce pays un reportage de Philippe
Rochot mesdames et messieurs bonsoir et
oui notre invité pour cette édition est
le grand vulcanologue Haroun tazev qui
arrive à l'instant de Sicile à Paris et
qui nous parlera dans quelques minutes
du tremblement de terre et des éruptions
de volcan qui paraissent devenus choses
quotidiennes depuis 8 jours voyons
d'abord les travaux du Conseil des
ministres de ce matin avant de se
séparer pour 15 jours car le prochain
conseil aura lieu le 22 août les membres
du gouvernement ont pris d'importantes
décisions avec notamment un programme de
10 ans pour lutter contre l'alcoolisme
et le tabagisme c'est de fléau bien plus
destructeur que la drogue dont il fut
question mercredi dernier et qui coûte à
l'ensemble du pays 10 milliards l'alcool
et 6 milliards le tabac une commission
présidée par le professeur Jean Bernard
de l'Académie française devra avoir
élaboré un programme d'action avant
l'été prochain dès à présent le
traitement des étidique sera amélioré
les contrôles d'alcool imis sur la route
multiplié on lancera de nouvelles
campagnes d'information et la publicité
sera encore davantage limitée au cours
du Conseil on est revenu sur divers
commentaires enregistrés ces jours
dernier à propos des haoses qui viennent
d'entrer en application le Premier
ministre à la sortie de l'Élysée a
répondu à ceux qui disent en substance
que la hausse du pétrole n'explique pas
l'élévation du coût de la vie monsieur
Debray ne nommait personne mais en fait
il répondait à ce que Monsieur Marchet a
dit avant le weekend et Monsieur Michel
Debray ce matin il faut considérer les
faits et et éviter toute agitation
verbale qui ignore les faits le fait
tous les Français le savent c'est que
cette année nous avons à payer 18
milliards de francs de plus au titre de
la facture pétrolière c'est une donnée
inéluctable l'an prochain nous onons à
payer 30 milliards de francs de plus
cela entraîne un certain nombre de
conséquences qui sont douloureuses mais
qui sont
inéductables ce que je voudrais dire
c'est essentiellement deux choses en
premier
dieu l'effort qui a déjà été accompis
par les Français permet à notre pays
d'affronter dans de meilleures
conditions que par le passé les
difficultés qui sont liées à ce nouveau
choc pétrolier la deuxième chose que je
voudrais dire est que dans l'effort
complémentaire qui doit être fait par
les
Français il faut que ceux qui sont les
moins favorisé puissent bénéficier d'une
atténuation des conséquences qui sont
liées aux décisions qui ont dû être
prises voilà pourquoi le gouvernement
prépare à l'heure actuelle pour la
rentrée un dispositif d'action
économique et
ma langue a glissé tout à l'heure c'est
bien monsieur Raymon bar Premier
ministre qui répondait donc à ce
qu'avait dit Monsieur marché monsieur de
prix le président de la République a
invité le gouvernement à prendre les
mesures que Monsieur bar vient d'évoquer
pour aider nos compatriotes les plus
défavorisés avant la fin du mois de
septembre c'est-à-dire au plus tard dans
6 semaines je reviendrai aux travaux du
Conseil dans un instant la CGC
Confédération générale des cadres a
annoncé aujourd'hui sa volonté de
resserrer ses contacts avec les
confédérations ouvrières pour étudier
les conditions d'une roste commune
constatant je cite que le gouvernement
sans tête a refusé toute concertation
réelle avec les organisations syndicales
revendication que de son côté monsieur
segéi exprimé ce matin même en certain
qu'un divers problèmes sociaux tels que
celui de la sécurité sociale le SMIG les
problèmes de la fiscalité qui est à
réformé aussi dans notre pays doivent
faire l'objet d'une négociation
tripartite gouvernement patronat
syndicat il a d'autres problèmes qui
relèvent de la compétence des branches
professionnelles de certains ministère
ou des entreprises et bien il faut que
les négociations aient lieu à tous les
niveaux mais je doute que le
gouvernement actuellement et le patronat
soient dans l'état d'esprit d'engager de
telles négociations soucieux de traiter
dans le détail toutes ces questions et
après avoir donc eu aujourd'hui comme
invité monsieur si nous aurons comme
invité demain Anne de midi Monsieur
Robert Boulin ministre du Travail avec
lequel nous ferons le tour des problèmes
nombreux qui se posent dans son secteur
je reviens vous disais-je au Conseil des
ministres le commerce extérieur de la
France était l'un des sujets les plus
importants traités ce matin après
l'augmentation des prix de pétrole en
1974 notre commerce extérieur avait été
longtemps déficitaire puis il s'était
redressé mais le nouvel alourdissement
de la facture pétrolière compromet de
rchef cet équilibre il faut donc
accomplir de nouveaux efforts pour
vendre davantage de produits made in
France afin de payer nos importations de
pétrole et de matières premières des
mesures seront annoncées le mois
prochain pour le gouvernement le
problème est clair la France doit payer
son pétrole en 78 la facture s'est
élevée à 49 milliards de francs cette
année ce sera 67 milliards et en 1980 80
milliards il faut compenser cette
brutale augmentation des importations
d'énergie car l'équilibre du commerce
extérieur est fondamental pour la bonne
santé du franc cette année la France
pourra payer la note grâce au secteur
qui exporte beaucoup comme l'automobile
les biens d'équipement ou
l'agroalimentaire mais aussi grâce à ce
qu'on appelle les services comme par
exemple la matière grise que nous
vendons à l'étranger par l'intermédiaire
des sociétés
d'ingénierie mais cela ne suffira pas
l'an prochain pour le ministre du
Commerce extérieur il faut que nous
importions moins en fabriquant
nous-mêmes certains produit et surtout
il faut que nous exportions toujours
davantage dans toutes les branches
d'activité il faut que nos
procédure augmente le nombre des
exportateurs qu'il y ait plus
d'entreprises petites ou moy yen qui
puisse exporter et une gamme de produits
plus variés parce que c'est ça la
stabilité si on ne vend que des grands
ensembles il faut en vendre aussi des
grands projet spectaculairire c'est pas
mal ça intéresse tout le secteur lourd
de l'économie française mais s'il y a
des troubles dans un pays une récession
c'est d'habitude ce genre de projet là
qui disparaissent les premiers tandis
que si on vend beaucoup de produits très
différents ça donne une base très large
à notre commerce extérieur et c'est un
élément de de de stabilité et de
solidité alors j'ai constaté que très
souvent nos procédures dans ces domaines
du du je vous dirais du du quotidien des
biens de consommation dectou ménager du
petit équipement sur catalogue elles
sont compliquées et elles sont assez
lentes et ce que j'ai proposé au conseil
ce matin c'est une série de mesures ces
techniques mais qui raccourcissent les
délais et qui simplifient il y a
exactement 5 ans le 7 août
1974 le Parlement votait la réforme de
la Radio Télévision le RTF disparaissait
et faisait place à Sep société
nationales dont les trois chaînes de
télévision à l'occasion de ce 5e
anniversaire monsieur le cas au conseil
de ce matin faisait le point de
l'application de cette loi qui a apporté
des améliorations importantes dans la
diversification la gestion et la
responsabilité du service public de
radio et de télévision le Conseil des
ministres a rappelé que la loi
s'imposait à tous et que le gouvernement
avait le devoir de veillir à son
application si des formations politiques
demandent l'abandon du principe du
monopole public il leur appartient de
présenter dans la clarté des
propositions de loi à cette fin le
président de la République a demandé que
la personnalité et l'autonomie des
sociétés de programme soit affirmé il a
rappelé que les conseils
d'administration devaient être appelés à
délibérer sur toute question importantes
engageant l'activité et l'orientation de
ces sociétés les présidents doivent
veiller à informer personnellement le
public sur tous les aspects de la vie
des entreprises qu'il
dirigent deux graves sujets de
préoccupation pour l'Espagne à nouveau
un garde civil a été tué près de Bilbao
et deux autres blessés dans un attentat
dont les auteurs en tirait plus de 50
balles contre la jeep où les gardes
circulaient d'après les premières
informations l'attentat aurait été
commis par l'taa militaire l'incendie
d'hier à Lioret Delmar province de
géronne a fait de nombreuses victimes
dès hier à notre édition de 23h la
télévision espagnole nous envoyit en
direct des images des premiers secours
voici ce soir un reportage sur les
causes de al des vill là ombragé d'hier
il ne restent dans les pinettes calciné
que des murs blancs perdus dans les
cendres noires c'était un petit paradis
pour vacanciers c'est aujourd'hui un
paysage irréel que le temps gris qui
couvre la Costa Brava en plus désolé
encore dans ces villes-là pour petits
vacanciers personne hier n'a cru au
danger de cet incendie que chacun voyait
se développer à 5 ou 6 kmè depuis sa
terrasse tout était si calme aujourd'hui
dans cet environnement de cauchemar on
revoit bien sûr les choses
différemment il était 2h je dis à ma
femme venez on va allit faire un tour on
va regarder comment que ça se passe
derrière et c'est là à peu près un bon
quart d'heure ça montait il est vu du
vent du vent incroyable vent qui
soufflaitin et puis je vous dis les
flammes ils arrivaient presque en haut
là alors on l' a dit on se dépêche quand
même de faire les les valises pour
partir on l' mis tous comme ça là-dedans
puis on est parti je d les femmes étes
Arros nous est-ce que les les forces de
police espagnoles sont venus demander
aux gens de la zone d'évacuer rien du
tout non non ma femme est là rien rien
rien alors c'est pour ça
là juste dans le trouz voyez qu'il y a
des gens là-bas non il y en a combien
qui avait de morts là-bas c'est ici à
une trentaine de mètres de cette route
en contrebas dans un vallon qui ont été
retrouvés les corps des 12 des 22
victimes de cet incendie 12 personnes
qui vraisemblablement essayaient de fuir
le feu et qui se sont retrouvés prises
en étau entre deux murs de flammes cela
a une trentaine de mètres de cette route
où circulaent pourtant à peu près
librement les moyens des sauveteurs on
imagine la fureur des pompiers et des
sauvteurs lorsqu'ils ont découvert ces
12 corps calcinés ici à peine à 30 m il
y a plus grave que cela c'est que tous
ceux qui essayent de comprendre depuis
hier soir ce qui s'est passé ici à yor
d'mar les pompiers les policiers les
témoins aussi tous ceux qui essayent de
savoir comment ce feu gigantesque a pu
prendre naissance sont arrivés
aujourd'hui à la même conclusion il
s'agit d'un incendie
criminel pour certains il ne s'agirait
pas seulement de l'œuvre d' vulgaire
pyoman des 2000 incendies enregistrées
depuis le début de l'année en Espagne
750 au moins ont été l'œuvre de criminel
et certains hommes politiques et des
plus sérieux affirment même que cette
pyromanie n'est peut-être pas autre
chose qu'une manœuvre terroriste d'un
nouveau genre destiné à déstabiliser la
démocratie vous avez vu hier sur cet
écran les extraordinaires images de la
plus grande pollution de la mer qui se
soit jamais produite début juin dans le
golfe du Mexique un puit de pétrole
sous-marin a sauté il envoie chaque jour
dans la mer 4000 tonnes de pétrole et
aujourd'hui l'on peut dire qu'il a
déversé dans les eaux davantage de
polluant que l'amococadiste l'année
dernière 240000 tonnes on a donc affaire
à la plus grande catastrophe du genre le
pétrole que crache le volcan sous-marin
avance de 20 à 30 km par jour en
direction du sud des États-Unis et voici
que les nappes touchent les côtes du
Texas selon Monsieur redader le pompier
volant américain 4 à 5 semaines seront
encore nécessaire pour parvenir à
contrôler le fameux pu de pétrole
sous-marin cela représenterait au BAMO
encore 200000 tonnes de pollution dans
la mer il s'agissait là d'une
catastrophe à l'origine de laquelle il y
a l'homme ce sont des hommes qui ont
foré le puis de pétrole mais voici que
depuis quelques jours une série de
catastrophes naturelles s'abattent sur
diverses parties du monde le tremblement
de terre à San Andreas en loin de San
Francisco et la faille ainsi créée qui
avance vers la grande ville américaine
un léger tremblement de terre en B il y
a 3 jours un tremblement de terre en
Roumanie la nuit dernière en Italie
l'Etna est entré en éruption et vomi
salunasief voilà 30 ans que vous
fréquentez l'Etna vous connaissez bien
ce volcan à votre avis est-il possible
d'expliquer sur les images qui vont
venir ce qui se passe je vais vous
demander à vous de les
commenter et bien on voit ici l'arrivée
de la coulée de lave qui est descendu
très vite en moins de 24 heures depuis
des bouches qui se sont ouverte vers 500
m d'altitude jusque ici nous sommes à
850 m audessus du niveau de la mer à
l'entrée de la bourgade fornazo alors
est-ce qu'à votre avis cette éruption
est dangereuse euh oui et non oui et non
si elle dure fornazo risque d'être
détruite et même plus que fornazo tout
dépend de la durée et de et du débit des
nouvelles coulées et d'autre part je
redoute un petit
peu que des explosions se produisent
comme elle vientent d'avoir lieu
d'ailleurs au début de la semaine au
cratè somito et qu'alors ce soit les
touristes qui sont là par milliers tous
les jours qui n' fassent les qui n'en
soient les victimes mais alors pourquoi
l'activité actuelle est-elle plus
préoccupante que d'habitude est-ce que
ça veut dire que la croûte terrestre est
en train de bouger normalement ou non
non non c'est l'Etna l'Etna est un
volcant en activité pratiquement
ininterrompu c'est un des volcans les
plus actifs qui soit au monde et à cause
de cela pour les volcanologues l'un des
plus intéressants qui soit parce qu'ils
peuvent étudier le phénomène à loisir et
de temps en temps le l'activité modérée
qui est la sienne culmine en un
paroxisme comme celui qui est là
actuellement paroxisme qui a été
extrêmement violent jusqu'à la nuit de
lundi de dimanche à lundi oui mais c'est
un un des volcans que vous connaissez le
mieux et apparemment vous vous êtes un
peu déconcerté ah ben oui parce que
cette éruption-ci ne ressemble pas à
toutes les éruption que je connais de
l'eetna et pas seulement moi mais j'ai
parlé à j'en arrive je je viens de
débarquer de l'avion ce matin je parlais
encore à un vieux guide qui a 85 ans et
qui m'a dit qu'il n'a jamais vu une
éruption comme celle-ci en quoi est-elle
différente d'abord parce qu'il y a eu
cette fabuleuse émission de gaz à très
forte pression c'est monté à des
milliers de mètres de hauteur et ça a
fait un panage colossal extraordinaire
comme je nen ai jamais vu à l'Etna un
panage de volcan circum Pacifique un
panage de volcan explosif alors que
l'thna n'est pas explosif ça c'est la
première chose et la deuxième ce qui
m'inquiète maintenant c'est qu'après
avoir donné naissance à quatre coulées
de lave successives et très brèves
chacune maintenant une 5ème reprend par
la par l'une des premières
bouches il ne dégaz plus du tout la lave
sort elle est dégazée mais le gaz ne
sort plus comme il est sorti au début il
ne sort même pas de façon normale avec
des explosions plusou moins spectaculire
alors il y a quelque part une poche
gigantesque qui pour j'ai peur que j'ai
peur je me trompe peut-être mais j'ai
peur que ce gaz ne s'accumule sous les
bouchon qui obturent les grands cratères
somito il y en a quatre et que lorsque
la pression des gaz dépassera la
résistance mécanique des bouchons le
tout ne saute et avec les milliers de
touristes qu'il y a tous les jours c'est
un carnage qui est possible AR y a-t-il
à votre avis une relation de cause à
effet entre les divers tremblements de
terre que je rappelais il y a un instant
et cette éruption non la terre n'a pas
la fièvre enfin les entrailles de la
terre n'ont pas une fièvre générale non
non c'est une coïncidence qui cette
éruptionci on en parle elle n'est pas
colossale c'est une petite éruption de
rien du tout à part ça mais c'est l'Etna
c'est c'est en pleine Europe c'est avec
des milliers de d'Européens qui sont là
est-ce que vous pensez qu'un jour on
arrivera à faire des prévisions
correctes euh oui je crois oui oui et
notamment à Lena nous sommes en train de
terminer le la construction d'un
observatoire que j'ai demandé il y a des
années qui est en train d'être achevé et
à partir d'octobre nous lançons un
programme d'étude extrêmement moderne
extrêmement sérieux extrêmement
euh organisé mais le dernier
observatoire qui était sur le vésu
justement il a été recouvert par de la
lave non celui de l'Etna celui de l'Etna
a été recouvert justement en 71 lors de
l'éruption 71 et en remplacement de cela
nous avons maintenant un observatoire
qui sera certainement le meilleur
observatoire du monde au point de vue
volanologique à partir de septembre
octobre il sera terminé pourquoi et fort
heureusement d'ailleurs la France semble
je dis semble je n'en sais rien être à
l'abri de tout cela elle elle est assez
bien elle elle n'a pas de volcan sur son
territoire en a si les les volcans du
Massif central se réveilleront un jour
enfin ce ne sera pas catastrophique peu
probable il y a des tremblements de
terre ils sont peu fréquents et
habituellement pas très fort quoi qu'il
y ait tout même des tremblement terire
comme celui de 1909 en Provence par
exemple il surviendrait aujourd'hui dans
la même région avec son épicentre du
côté de salon de salon Provence et bien
au lieu d'avoir 1000 meurs il y en
aurait 10 ou ou 30000 ou 50000 mais
c'est rare la France est un pays comme
l'Allemagne comme la la Grande-Bretagne
le bénilux et le nord de la de l'Europe
une région géologiquement assez stable
moins stable que cette région là
d'ailleurs mais avec peu de tremblement
de terre et extrêmement peu de
volcanisme puisque les dernières
éruptions volcaniques daté remontent à
x merci infiniment en Irak le nouveau
Premier ministre Saddam Hussein frappe
fort sous l'accusation de complot dirigé
contre le régime 22 personnes ont été
condamnées à mort dont cinq étaient de
haut dirigeants et parmi eux deux
ministres le vice-premier ministre et le
ministre de l'éducation en exercice
jusqu'à ces tout derniers jours ils ont
été cet après-midi passés par les armes
en Italie le nouveau président du
Conseil monsieur Cossiga démocrate
chrétien a nommé aujourd'hui les
sous-secrétaires d'état de son cabinet
ils seront 50 5 en majorité des
démocrates chrétiens en Iran 13
journalistes du quotidien aadegan vient
d'être arrêtés leur journal est occupé
par les Gardiens de la Révolution les
nouveaux maîtres du pays les religieux
fort du succès qu'ils viennent de
remporter aux dernières élections à la
Constituante semble décidé à mettre la
presse au pas une nouvelle loi condamne
à 6 mois de prison tout journaliste qui
critiquera dans ses articles les
décisions de l'ayat khaminii et cette
mesure touche en partie la presse
étrangère et nos confrères de la chaîne
de télévision américaine NB ici ont été
expulsés aujourd'hui d'Iran nos envoyés
spéciaux Philippe Rochot et Alain Pagano
qui reviennent d'Iran ont pu néanmoins
réaliser une série de reportages avec
difficulté il nous montre ici en édition
spéciale et Salo le nouveau visage de la
vie
quotidienne l'islam règle aujourd'hui la
vie quotidienne de 35 millions
d'Iraniens dans la ville sainte de Rome
où le pouvoir islamique s'est installé
ils sont chaque matin des centaines
devant les bureaux de l'ayatollah Romé
chômeurs employés non payés petit
mécontent il tente désespérément de
donner une lettre au chef
religieux cette femme par exemple est
venu demander de l'argent au Guide de la
République islamique elle a perdu son
fils pendant la Révolution et elle veut
aussi que l'imam romeini prononce son
[Musique]
divorce tous les problèmes de la vieenne
des iraniens s'empil ici dans les
bureaux des mollas les ministres et les
secrétaires de l'ayatollah romini ces
hommes des mosquées précipité d'un jour
à l'autre à la tête d'un État dont ils
ne connaissent pas les rouages et qui
règle chaque cas au jour le
jour cette femme a fait 200 km pour
venir se plaindre dans les bureaux de
l'ayatah ROM elle voulait emprunter de
l'argent à la banque islamique on lui a
refusé dit-elle parce qu'elle était une
cet homme ce paysan estime qu'il fait
les frais de la nouvelle réforme agraire
on lui avait promis une terre mais quand
il a voulu prendre possession des lieux
elle était déjà
occupé ce ce ministre religieux explique
qu'il reçoit beaucoup de plaines comme
celle-ci les gens viennent demander de
l'argent et des terr et à présent ilent
une
voiture dans les milliers de lettres qui
s'empilent sur les bureaux des mollas la
principale revendication des petits gens
qui écrivent est d'abord avoir un
nouveau
logement la devise des partisans de
roméie les pauvres doivent habiter chez
les riches les villas de ceux qui ont
pris la fuite à la révolution ou qui ont
été arrêtés sont réquisitionné et donné
aux pauvres comme ses orphelins
handicapés les comités rom les ont
installé ici dans la villa du maire de
Tan fusillé au printemps dernier c'est
la revanche des laissés pour compte de
l'Ancien Régime tous les meubles et les
objets de valeur ont été vendus sauf le
téléviseur qui distrait ses oubliés du
régime
[Musique]
impérial 200 villas ont été ainsi
réquisitionné dans téran pour y loger
les pauvres et les
[Musique]
orphelins
on confisque les maisons des gens qui en
possèdent plusieurs on leur en laisse
une seule on y loge les pauvres et les
orphelins comme ici ou alors on vend les
maisons réquisitionné et on partage
l'argent avec le
peuple l'argent c'est bien le principal
souci des Iraniens chaque matin il sont
des centaines à faire la queue devant
les banques et au guichet churs qui sont
plus pay et retirer leurs économies
spéculateurs qui achètent des monnaies
étrangères ou des pièces d'or Iraniens
qui veulent fuir le pays et tentent de
changer ses rials inutiles dans lesquels
ils n'ont plus confiance contre des
dollars la morale islamique n'a pourtant
pas empêché la flambée des prix en 6
mois ils ont augmenté de 20 à 25 %
surtout les fruits qui se payent au même
prix à Thiran que sur n'importe quel
marché parisien l'Iran ne connaît pas la
pénurie sauf pour la viande on en trouve
que deux fois par semaine et il faut
faire 2 heur de queue l'ayatollah Romé
avait défendu de la congeler pratique
contraire à l'islam mais il a dû lever
cet
[Musique]
interdit devant les difficultés
économiques où se débat le pays les
Iraniens ont retrouvé leur vieux réflexe
spéculé sur le tapis perçant ces
merveilles de l'Orient il les payent en
monnaie locale
pour les revendre en Europe et obtenir
ainsi des devises étrangères à bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
marché jamais les Bazaris les
commerçants du bazar n'ont fait autant
de Bénéfic à tel point qu'il sont sans
doute les grands gagnants de la
Révolution il n plus
acheter les tapis per mais les Iraniens
surtoutux des classes moyennes les
achètent par dizain au bazar de
Tan pour moi le tapis c'est comme des
dollars comme je ne peux pas acheter de
dollars car c'est trop cher pour nous
c'est le seul moyen de sortir mon argent
du pays voyz il nous oblige àevenir des
voleurs pas re
[Musique]
voleurs un air de liberté flotte
pourtant sur tan on le voit à
l'université centre de la contestation
en tout genre où 200000 étudiants se
sont livrés un combat idéologique sans
précédent l'istoire de l'Iran avec mois
deetard pour cause de
révolution
[Applaudissements]
le simple fait de pouvoir distribuer des
tractes à la sortie de l'université
c'est déjà un pas vers la liberté pour
la prièreisoire
Deiran
DESS
le noust desè thre française nous
pouvons cette année prendre comme
exemple des pièces plus ou moins engagé
ce que nous pouvions pas faire l'année
dernière mais contraire il y a des idées
qu'il faudrait pas
tellement par exemple bon par exemple
c'est pas la peine de faire
l'anger nveage de la dans la République
islamique apparaî aussi à l'université
de
téranéternel conflit entre celles qui
ont gardé le voile celle qui reste vêue
à l'occidental celle qui se couvre
depuis la Révolution aujourd'hui la
femme sans voile se sent menacée celle
qui cache son visage s'estime
libéré cette étudiante affirme qu'elle
est plus libre qu'avant autrefois on
vivait dans la société mais on ne
comptait pas aujourd'hui les gens qui
sont habillés comme nous sont mieux
considér si on fait la comparaison on
voit qu'on est plus libre que sous
l'ancien régime qui était celui d'un
tyran filles qui ont mis de qui son voil
mais encore jusque maintenant encore on
est sait pas qu'estce qui va
arriver mais la rigueur de la loi
islamique a déjà gagné la vie
quotidienne des
Iraniens vient d'interdire la musique
pendant le Ramadan c'est une for um du
peuple il exige aussi que les hommes et
les femmes ne fréquentent plus ensemble
les piscines même dans les grands hôtels
le matin comme ici est réservé aux
femmes nous avons dû tourner ces images
en cachette l'équipe d'Antenne 2
essentiellement masculine s'est en vu
refuser l'entrée et c'est cette femme à
droite qui nous montre du doigt qui nous
a dénoncé comme des
voyeurs l'après-midi est réservé aux
hommes les femmes même vêtues n'ont pas
le droit d'entrer les religieux
affirment que les ennemis du peuple ont
voulu mélanger les hommes et les femmes
non pas pour leur plaisir mais pour leur
destruction mais pour d'autres cette
mesure est surtout l'abolition d'un
privilège les gens qui utilisaient les
plage mix c'était 10 ou 15 % d'ensemble
de la population plupart les autres
voulaient utiliser la plage jusqu'à
maintenant il avaiit pas la possibilité
parce qu'il n'avait
pas
accepter ce genre de choses maintenant
pour déviser ça nous avons donné la
possibilité de toutes les femmes et tous
les hommes de de utiliser leur le plage
et jusqu'à maintenant c'était pour les
élites les mixages de pas de plage
c'était pour les
élites ce nouvel ordre moral qui règne
en Iran ce sont les gardiens de la
révolution qui le font respecter ces
nouveaux maîtres du pays contrôlent tout
dans la rue si la population suit les
consignes de l'ayatollah si le jeûne du
ramadan est respecté si la tenue des
femmes est conforme au Coran le nouveau
régime iranien est aujourd'hui sur la
balance va-t-il verser totalement dans
l'Islam ou s'ouvrir à nouveau au monde
occidental deux conceptions du monde se
regarde et s'affronte de leur choc
sortira sans doute un nouvel
Iran une information effroyable au
Cambodge plus de 2 millions de personnes
je dis bien 2 millions de personnes sont
en passe de mourir de faim estiment les
représentants de l'enu et de la
Croix-Rouge internationale qui
reviennent de là-bas et qui l'ont dit au
New York Times pour eux le Cambodge
risque de connaître une tragédie
surpassant celle du Vietnam et l'un
d'eux a affirmé j'ai vu un certain
nombre de pays ravagé au cours de ma
carrière je n'ai jamais rien vu de tel
il chiffre à 100 millions de dollars
c'est-à-dire à plus de 400 millions de
francs actuels le montant de l'aide
d'urgence indispensable la cour d'appel
d'axent-provence a décidé d'accorder à
l'Union sud-africaine l'extradition de
Monsieur Rudy celui-ci ancien secrétaire
d'État à l'information en union
sud-africaine est accusé dans son pays
d'avoir détourné de grosses sommes
d'argent la station de sport d'hiver
Isala 2000 créée à une centaine de
kilomètres de Nice dans les altpes par
une société britannique il y a une
dizaine d'années a été racheté
aujourd'hui en totalité par un groupe
libanais la société internationale pour
l'aménagement et le développement
foncier football il y avait déjà dans
l'équipe de Nant un trocero il y en aura
désormais deux car enzo est arrivé Enzo
trocero le milieu de terrain
international d'Argentine qui s'est
entraîné ce matin pour la première fois
avec ses nouveaux coéquipiers il jouera
vendredi soir pour Nantes contre Monaco
voilà une recrue de choix pour les Nant
au sein de l'équipe desquel trocero
participera non seulement au championnat
mais bien sûr à la Coupe de France et à
la Coupe d'Europe 301
302 pronostic de Pierrette Bress pour le
ver de demain à angin il s'agit de trop
prix la elle donne d'abord le 19 et
Jacques Val qui est un chevix
extrêmement régulier ensuite 18 FAD qui
est la révélation de l'année dernière
puis le 10 godarling en anglais ça veut
dire vas-y chéri espérons que ça portera
bonheur à Pierrette Bress le numéro 20
hurgo cheval archiourageux qui court
souvent le numéro 12 fleur de prère le
numéro 7 imè le numéro 1 iris de gournet
et le numéro 8 fa Missol contrairement à
ce que ces images pouvaient vous faire
penser il s'agit bien je le répète de
trop de main à angin quant au l'OTO
nationale et bien 14 21 22 40 45 47 et
numéos complémentaire le 36 les
abateteurs de l'OTO ont compris de quoi
il s'agissait alors la météo maintenant
demain jeudi le temps sera généralement
très nuageux sur la moitié nord du pays
il pleuvera le matin de la Bretagne et
de la Vendé à la Normandie et ces pluies
se déplaceront jusqu'au centre et au
nord-est en cours de journée elles
seront suivies d'un temps variable et
plus frais avec éclaircis et inverse
alors sur la moitié sud de la France il
fera beau le matin mais le ciel
deviendra nuageux ens suite de laquité
au massive central et sur les Alpes et
le Sud-Est où quelques orages pourront
éclater c'est avant 23h vers 22h45 kerv
Claude vous présentera les dernières
informations de la journée n'oubliez
surtout pas demain antenne demi présenté
par Daniel lallian avec comme invité
d'honneur Monsieur Robert Boulin
ministre du Travail et si tel continue à
être votre bon plaisir nous nous
retrouverons demain soir ici même à 20h
bonne soirée
[Musique]
merci